les distilleries fonctionne environ
quatre mois dans l'année et près de six
heures par jour
aujourd'hui chaque usine dégage moins de
150 milligrammes par mètre cube de
particules fines à travers leurs
chaudières et c'est justement cette
norme qui a changé depuis décembre 2018
l'est devenu plus drastiques
l'europe exige que les producteurs
divise par trois les quantités de
poussières rejetées dans l'air
les chaudières devons être mise aux
normes et pour une petite unité comme
celle ci qui produit 400 mille litres de
rhum par an cela représente un
investissement considérable
on va devoir rajouter deux systèmes de
filtration
d'ailleurs nos chaudières donc il va
falloir faire des investissements qui
sont très onéreux on estime à plus de 2
millions d'euros les investissements
pour l'industrie la favorite c'est une
petite entreprise familiale
le problème principal se situe au niveau
des délais le gouvernement français
souhaite que les chaudières soit mise
aux normes dès cette année chose
impossible sur les producteurs de rhums
l'europe nous donne un délai 2025 voire
2030 pour faire ces investissements
la difficulté c'est que quand cette
directive européenne a été convertie
dans le droit national
on a retiré ce délai qualité de nos dix
séries des régions ultrapériphériques
donc de la martinique pour avoir une
application immédiate ce qui pour nous
est impossible
je pense que sur ce dossier là il ya une
ignorance de nos spécificités qui fait
qu'à un moment donné on veut aller vers
un faire quelque chose de classique
alors que nous ne nous sommes des
producteurs demain nous travaillons
partir de la bagasse ces vaccins cette
bagarre s'est produite en outre mers
partaient la canne à sucre
mais c'est une vraie source énergie nous
avons développé un siècle un stade
vertueux circuits courts il faut que ce
soit reconnue il faut qu'on puisse
préserver ce système on distillerie a
cependant anticiper les recommandations
de l'europe
ici à j aime le changement de chaudière
a eu lieu il ya déjà un an
san andres
en colossal qui est environ d'un million
d'euros pour cet équipement la dont
trois cent mille euros sont dédiés
uniquement traitement des fumées donc
pour en off les plus propres
ce changement là il était nécessaire
puisque la distillerie gm voulait
augmenter sa capacité de production pour
répondre à des besoins
donc il était nécessaire d'agrandir
notre capacité de chaudières les
producteurs de rhum sont donc toujours
en pourparlers avec le gouvernement pour
obtenir un délai pour changer leur
chaudière
en dernier recours il n'exclut pas
d'intenter une action en justice pour se
faire entendre